OK, I want to get ahead of what is going to
be a barrage of absolute B.S. garbage math.
This is what I'm calling a garbage math.
You are going to be hit left and right by
garbage math over the next few months.
And the goal of the garbage math will be for
you to think that Donald Trump deserves to
be reelected.
And we've already been starting to see some
of what I'm calling garbage math with corona
virus for a while.
So, for example, when Trump lists talk about
the total number of tests that have been done
in the United States, that's garbage math.
It doesn't tell us very much.
Tests per day are what matter tests per capita
are, what matter.
We're four months into this thing, right.
The cumulative number of tests that have been
done tell us very, very little.
Another example, over the last couple of months,
we've seen such economic destruction that
it now opens the door to wild, meaningless
claims about growth rates in certain industries,
which are already being touted as huge victories.
Now, I want to give you a really specific
example.
There's been this headline floating around.
Air travel surges, air travel and bookings
surge.
One hundred and twenty percent.
The New York Times actually wrote about this
when this started being touted.
So understand when Corona virus hit.
Air travel dropped by one estimate, 96 percent.
So when you say air travel surges one hundred
and twenty percent, it has surged 120 percent
or roughly doubled from almost zero.
OK, so imagining that air travel is going
well completely ignores just basic math.
Let's look at some numbers.
If you start with what would be one hundred
percent, right.
Like full air travel and you then experience
and 96 percent decrease to air travel, you
end up with four percent of the air travel
you started with.
You start with something.
You take away 96 percent.
You're left with four percent.
If you then increase air travel by one hundred
and twenty percent, air travel is still down
91, one percent from where it was.
This is just a common function of how percentages
and growth rates work.
If you lose 50 percent of something, you need
to gain 100 percent to get back to where you
were.
If I have one hundred dollars in stock and
that stock loses 50 percent of its value.
My hundred dollars is now worth fifty dollars
to get back to one hundred dollars.
I need that 50 bucks to increase.
One hundred percent.
And this is the crux of a ton of the disinformation,
propaganda, propaganda, garbage, math that
you are going to be hit with over the next
few months as the recovery hopefully starts
to happen, depending on how deadly coronavirus
remains and how bad Wave two is.
You are going to see a lot of this stuff.
I'll give you some other examples.
Jobs have so imploded that they will start
using job growth numbers that will be meaningless
because of the base numbers that are being
used.
Understand that we lost more than 20 percent
of our workforce so far.
We might recover five percent of the current
workforce and they will say, hey, we're already
a quarter of the way back.
That's not how growth rates work.
If you lose 20 percent of the workforce and
then you gain back five percent of that reduced
number, you're only gaining 19 percent of
what you lost.
Not 25.
So understand how these growth rates work.
The one that will really be weaponized is
probably going to be GDP.
We in all likelihood are going to see historic
GDP loss numbers for the second quarter in
the United States.
We're not going to get those numbers until
sometime in August.
Most likely.
So normally the numbers would be, for example,
like, oh, GDP in Q2 went up.
Point five percent.
Usually you annualize that.
So point five percent over four quarters would
be like ontrack for two percent GDP growth
for the year.
OK.
The decline in the second quarter is going
to be massive.
It could be 10 percent.
Could be 12 percent.
Could be 25 percent.
Imagine it's 15 percent.
If you annualize that 15 percent, one quarter
loss, it would be like 60 percent for the
year.
It's not going to really tell us much because
in all likelihood, in the third quarter, if
things go as as are sort of expected, we're
going to start to see a recovery.
And remember that recovery in GDP would only
be a fraction of what was lost in the second
quarter.
The headlines and Trump and others are going
to say, for example, imagine that we lose
15 percent in Q2 and gain five percent in
Q3 relative to those previous numbers.
The trumpet will say, oh, my God, five percent
in a quarter, we're on track for 20 percent
GDP growth.
If you annualize it, even China doesn't grow
20 percent in a year.
And of course, that would be wrong because
we will have just suffered one of the if not
the greatest GDP loss in American American
history.
And there would be no reason to annualize
third quarter GDP growth.
If we have it, given that it is a year with
massive ups and downs.
So the concern I have is that the timing of
that could be very, very pernicious.
We are likely to learn the Q3 GDP numbers
at the end of October.
That is days before the presidential election.
And it is going to present the perfect opportunity
for Donald Trump to do what will essentially
be like 96 hours of propaganda, confusing
people about Q3 GDP numbers to justify his
reelection.
And it may work.
I'm trying to stay ahead of it.
I don't want you to fall for the garbage math.
And the reason why it's important to understand
is that this is one where there's a couple
of different things.
First of all, you don't want to get tricked
by bad math.
We all want to have basic math and statistics
understanding.
But number two, policymakers are going to
be using bad data to justify the policies
that they would be advocating for anyway and
pretending like it's where the facts are taking
us.
When the reality is they'd be advocating for
the same policies no matter what, and they'd
be advocating for the reelection of Donald
Trump no matter what.
They will claim victory.
They will claim mission accomplished.
Understand growth rates.
Understand percentages.
Don't fall for the garbage math.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter.
Let me know what other fuzzy math you are
seeing for lack of a better term.
And remember that you can get the Daily David
Pakman Show audio podcast for free on iTunes,
Stitcher, Google Play Pod.
Cast all of your favorite podcasting platforms,
sign up free and get the daily podcast,